half a decade of uninterrupted violence
370 thousand deaths more than 11 million
people displaced from their homes that's
like the entire state of Ohio there's no
end in sight Syria devolved from
peaceful demonstrations opposing an
authoritarian regime in 2011 to a
full-blown Civil War had seen the rise
of the Islamic state and outside
superpowers drawn into the carnage the
result the biggest humanitarian crisis
in the world so here's the situation
since 1966 the Alawite minority an
offshoot of Shiite Islam have been in
power in Syria this despite the fact
that all the whites represent just 12%
of the Syrian population the Sunni
Muslim population however represents
around 60% the current President Bashar
al-assad and Alawite took over in 2000
after the death of his father series
longtime ruler Hafez al-assad cut to
2011 and the Arab Spring the world
watched his uprisings in Tunisia and
Egypt quickly toppled their respective
dictators inspired by these events
Syrians took to the streets to protest
the oppressive rule of the sharla Saud
but instead of stepping down Assad
violently crushed the peaceful uprisings
using tanks artillery and gunships many
of the protesters responded by arming
themselves that's when the conflict took
on a sectarian nature Sunnis from other
parts of the Middle East like the Saudis
through their backing behind the rebels
Shiites like the Iranians gave their
support to the regime meanwhile the
jihadis of the Islamic state which used
the turmoil to seize territory attacked
both sides then there are major powers
like the US and Russia after a poison
attack in 2013 the US and Russia
cooperated to get UN inspectors to
destroy Syria's known chemical weapons
but in general the two powers have
skewed in very different directions over
this war simply put the u.s. is against
Assad and Russia supports him
Russia's used its UN Security Council
veto
heatedly to protect the regime both
countries are actively fighting inside
Syria against Islamic state and an al
Qaeda spin-off in the name of combating
terrorism but Russia uses the terrorists
tag to bomb other groups opposing Assad
including rebels supported by the US and
its allies finally here the Syrian
civilians in the middle of all of us
devastated by the fighting and
destruction Syrians are fleeing by the
millions into neighboring countries
straining resources and creating a
global refugee crisis now here is the
argument the US and Russia agree on the
need to end the war but not on how for
years the US has insisted Assad must go
but has since softened its stance on the
dictator in the interest of the broader
fight against the Islamic state
meanwhile Russia says it wants to keep
serious sovereign and independent by
backing Assad several efforts to resolve
the conflict through negotiations have
failed neither side has had enough of an
advantage in this war to get the other
to compromise on terms for peace or has
either been willing to do so for the
sake of Syria